bring in former counselor to then
president trump kellyanne conway she is
the author of a new book here's the deal
a memoir and it's a great book i'm about
halfway through kellyanne great to see
you thank you brett
there's a lot in this book
about your time in in the trump
administration but also a lot of other
things about politics and and your your
previous history i want to ask you just
about last night and what you've seen so
far in the primaries is there a theme
developing here
on on either side can you kind of paint
a picture for the midterms for
for where we stand
there is brett and i think it's a little
past this prologue in terms of the 2022
midterms this is pretty typical for the
party in power in the first midterm we
know that president clinton suffered 52
seat loss in 1994 president obama
famously referred to his 63 seat loss in
the house in 2010 as a quote shellacking
so one would think that president biden
would
would endorse something similar and we
see
early twinings of that don't we i think
the two major themes coming out of the
primary so far are number one record
enthusiastic turnout in these republican
primaries people feel energized they're
going to the ballot box they're very
upset about what they see with respect
to inflation energy immigration putin
and ukraine and a whole sundry list of
problems in this country that didn't
exist before a short time ago number two
i think what you see in these races is
that
where president trump has endorsed in a
candidate
that candidate is surrounded by other
non-endorsed candidates also running as
america first candidates they want to
somehow hew closely to the policy
accomplishments of president trump and
you're seeing this in very crowded
primaries in pennsylvania which you just
reported on in ohio
in north carolina and the list goes on
and on
i think on the other side brett the
democratic party is it's a fascinating
case study so far in these primaries
they don't have the record turnout that
the republicans have in some of these
states however there's a little bit of a
schism going on you have some
more traditional moderate democrats
running some with president biden's
endorsement and they're going up against
these bernie sanders or elizabeth warren
or aoc or all of the above endorsed
candidates and in some cases the more
radical candidates are winning so i
think you're seeing both parties uh
paying very close attention to these
primaries and we're going to see i
believe a monster year for the
republicans in in the fall typically
that happens but i also think that the
issue set right now does not favor
president biden he doesn't seem to have
any kind of course correction that you
would see from a president whose numbers
are under water we were just talking to
governor camp down in georgia and
obviously those results
seem to be that georgia was ready to
move on from 2020. in this book you say
you were one of the only advisors to
tell
president trump at the time uh that that
he had essentially lost and to accept it
you write in politics 101 you don't tell
the american people what's important to
them they tell you on some days it
seemed the campaign viewed the coveted
pandemic the same way they viewed
hillary or comey or big tech just
another political enemy standing between
trump and reelection and you go on
pretty tough on jared kushner in this
book
repeatedly referred to as the de facto
chief of staff the shadow secretary of
state the real 2020 campaign manager
jarrod had high tailed it to the middle
east just as soon as the campaign brad
and he ran lost the midwest
and the election victory he had so
confidently predicted had not
materialized kind of straight talk
it's straight talk i don't know any
other way and it's all fact checked and
true i'm heartbroken that president
trump didn't win a second term there's a
lot of unfinished business and so many
unraveling of great policies that he put
forth i think that's part of why he's
motivated to seriously consider to run
again brett but the 2020 campaign
had a a certain different tenor tone
and substance in the 2016 campaign in
2016 we were the underdogs
underestimated underfunded under
understaffed and that's a very donald
trump way to be to really turn on its
head this fiction of electability that
pretends i know if you will or won't win
rather than do what we did which is
focus on the electoral colleges which is
electoral college vote which is how you
do or don't win i believe in 2020 they
prove the old adage to be true the
fastest way to make a small fortune is
to have a very large one and waste most
of it 1.4 billion dollars and not much
of it left for ads in those swing states
late in the game
also you know cove had changed the way
president trump was able to campaign
he's a rally guy he likes to go and
connect with the voters it allowed
president biden to sort of hide a little
bit from the voters here now that
benefited him but but i think to run on
policy is the cautionary tale here to
make sure people understand what they
accomplish are and how they affect their
daily lives let me finish with this uh
you said you've told president trump
elections are about the future not the
past
you you talk about the job description
going forward in 2024 and it's not the
who but the what and the strength in the
gop you write for the republican party
lies in its policies and its peoples
and its people voters applaud gop's
commitment to fiscal issues national
security and social issues so that's the
ticket
that's the ticket and uh certainly when
i say elections about the future not the
past let me just say one thing about the
past here we have many voters right now
saying
i
my life was much better not that long
ago and i wanted back so in that regard
they are looking behind them to look
forward a little bit how do we get that
energy independence how do we get the
two dollar gas how do we get border
security how do we get putin out of
ukraine and iran to stop salivating as a
nuclear capable threat to israel and the
list goes on and on but in terms of you
know people are looking at their own
they want a fighter but the question is
are you fighting for yourself or are you
fighting for them and voters usually do
they appreciate people who are fighting
for them that was the magic of trump
2016 and i would say his presidency
brett which which is people felt he was
delivering for the forgotten man
forgotten woman a forgotten child so to
the extent he wants to do that he should
do it is there a trump candidate 2024
he would like to he sees a lot of
unfinished business and like a majority
of voters in everybody's polls brett
people are hurting and they're very
frustrated with the direction that this
white house has taken us into as a
nation on the policies that affect them
every single day so i think those two
things president trump can stand up and
say i had a better economy more border
security putin
china kim jong-un all contained in a way
they're not now and number two um it's i
want to rematch with biden because i can
go to him toe to toe but it whoever runs
if president trump says he's not running
which i believe he would like to whoever
runs is going to have to pick up that
america first mantle because those
policy prescriptions were very popular
and you see the opposite that now in
this current white house but you know
voters don't ask who can win voters ask
who can lead the pundits and the media
we sometimes ask who can who can win who
can win well that was my next question
voters ask who can lead who can win
could he win
well i think the person who can win is
the one who connects with the people and
convincingly talks about policy every
single day not personal grievances not
just the past but the future and the
policy prescriptions that everybody
wants and look i think so long as the
biden harris white house does not do
what president clinton president obama
and so many other leaders have done
which is say you know what this has not
been a great time for the home team
we're going to do a course correction
we're going to admit some mistakes and
we're going to admit that people are
hurting and come out with solutions
they're very reactionary
they talk about gun control after a
tragic unspeakable school shooting they
talk about abortion after the roe league
they talk about putin after he invades
ukraine it's a very reactionary white
house and that's no way i think that
plus spite and unraveling the trump
policies no way to run a country all
right the book is here's the deal
kellyanne conway we appreciate it thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else